bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat cette semaine la
commission d' enquête sur le coût réel
de l'électricité a poursuivi ses
auditions les sénateurs ont entendu
mercredi la responsable des questions
nucléaire chez greenpeace
vous le savez cette commission d'
enquête a pour objectif de comprendre ce
qui composent aujourd'hui le coût réel
de l'électricité mais aussi de savoir si
l'énergie nucléaire est réellement
compétitive tout de suite sans plus
tarder retour sur cette audition bonne
matinée a tous bien m'écouter jour merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
cela dit vous n'aviez pas le choix c'est
un peu une obligation une commission
denquête on ne peut pas refuser de venir
vous avez été je crois un petit peu
briefé avant avant de venir ici donc on
va attaquer tout de suite je vous
demande airs de respecter la tradition
c'est à dire que je vais demander de
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité je vais vous demander
de lever la main droite et de dire je le
jure je vous en remercie alors pour
avancer tout de suite dans le vif du
sujet vous avez reçu un questionnaire de
notre rapporteur jean desessard qui va
vous relier les questions de manière à
ce qu'elles soient bien enregistré dans
dans nos traditions et je voudrais vous
demandera d'y répondre dans l'ordre a
priori mme sauf si dans votre
démonstration ça vous arrange de passer
d'une question à une autre un moment ou
un autre nous sommes en la matière assez
souple monsieur le rapporteur vous la
parole c'est donc là magnoni chargé des
questions nucléaires pour greenpeace
france ces questions un première de
façon générale les tarifs actuels de
l'électricité vous paraît style refléter
fidèlement le coût réel de l'électricité
en france qu'elle devrait être à vos
yeux l'évolution de ses coûts et de ses
tailles dans les dix années à venir
seconde question la france devrait-elle
selon vous prolonger la durée de vie des
centrales existantes
investir dans le développement de
nouvelle génération de réacteurs au p r
quatrième génération ou fa tout cela est
soit et où selon votre réponse
encourager une sortie progressive du
nucléaire en investissant massivement
dans les énergies renouvelables
troisième question quelle appréciation
portez vous filière par filière sur les
différents mécanismes de soutien aux
énergies renouvelables
quatrième question pour respecter les
autres les objectifs fixés par le
grenelle de l'environnement
quelle capacité de production
renouvelable par filière forêt et il
installé à combien pouvez-vous chiffré
cet investissement cinquième question le
caractère intermittent de la plupart des
énergies renouvelables de l'est quand
elle ne les compte t il pas un rôle
d'appoint en matière de production
d'électricité et dernière question
quelles actions convient-il
prioritairement de mener selon vous et
avec quels moyens afin de réduire la
consommation d'électricité en france
sophia majnoni d'intignano à bout là à
vous de les réponses vous nous laisser
un petit peu de temps après pour vous
poser éventuellement quelques questions
complémentaires oui bien sûr pas de
souci par contre juste pour vous dire
les questions 3 et 4 qui sont sur les
mécanismes de soutien filière par
filière les objectifs du grenelle partir
du moment où moi je suis en charge
spécifiquement des questions nucléaire
pour greenpeace
je ne pense pas avoir la compétence de
répondre à ces questions et je sais vous
avez vu leclerc avec lequel nous
travaillons sur ces sujets là donc à
travers la personne de raphaël claustré
je crois que c'était en édition
restreinte uniquement avec monsieur le
rapporteur nous apporte beaucoup de jeu
me répond je vais vous répondre sur les
aspects beaucoup plus nucléaire joker je
renvoie au clair alors sur les tarifs
actuels
de l'électricité très concrètement pour
nous le tarif actuel l'électricité ne
reflète pas la réalité des coûts de
production de l'électricité notamment de
par la prédominance dans notre mix
électrique du nucléaire 1 75% comme vous
le savez avec un certain nombre de coûts
qui ne sont pas des coûts cachés comme
on peut l'entendre parfois en revanche
qui sont des coups sous-évalué ou mal
pris en compte
j'ai donc en tête trois types de coups
le coût qui est lié à ce qu'on appelle
les charges de long terme les charges
futures que sont le démantèlement et la
gestion des déchets que je classerais
dans un premier paquet et un second
paquet qui est ce que nous appelons
l'assurance du risque nucléaire donc
l'assurance en cas d'accident nucléaire
majeur
donc tout ce qui concerne les coûts du
démantèlement et la gestion des déchets
le rapport de la cour des comptes a déjà
beaucoup avancé sur ce sujet mais a
notamment mis en évidence le fait qu'il
y avait des lacunes qui avait des
incertitudes et qu'a priori avec le
vocabulaire de la cour des comptes qui
avait une sous-évaluation de ses coûts
puisque si on fait une comparaison
internationale
edf est en deçà du minimum
internationale pour 58 réacteurs
je crois que le minimum est à 20
milliards et que des f&a est à 18 donc
on a une sous évaluation qui est assez
net avec un risque que dans les années
à venir certainement proche
il ya une obligation qui soit faite a2a
et edf de revoir ses modèles pour
l'évaluation des charges de
démantèlement et une augmentation des
provisions
comme le souligne la cour des comptes
s'est pas forcément significatif sur le
prix final du kilowattheure puisque ses
réparties sur une très longue durée
la problématique est que plus on
repousse cette réévaluation et plus
l'impact sera important
donc il faut prendre ça en compte c'est
qui le jour où il y aura cette
réévaluation il y aura une nécessité
d'augmenter des provisions qui sont
faites pour le démantèlement est que
plus cette réévaluation est retardé et
plus l'impact sur le prix d'électricité
sera important et difficile à digérer
pour les pour les consommateurs la
partie gestion des déchets qui et qui
fait l'objet à peu près du même type
d'incertitude tout simplement parce
qu'on a aujourd'hui un choix dans la
gestion des déchets qui consiste qui est
très particulier à la france qui
consiste à faire d'une part du
retraitement pour tout ce qui est
combustible usagé donc sortie du
réacteur et de gérer en stockage
géologique en grande profondeur les
déchets les plus dangereux
pour l'instant tout ça est l objet est
au stade d'expérimentation je parle pour
le stockage géologique avec un
laboratoire dont vous avez certainement
entendu parler qui est bur le coût final
de ce laboratoire puis de ce centre de
stockage n'est pas connu on ad on avait
des estimations à 15 milliards
aujourd'hui on a des estimations entre
28 et 35 milliards d'euros
si vous parlez avec l'andra et vous
diront que même ils savent pas donc on a
un coût à long terme de la gestion des
déchets qui est pour l'instant pas
connues entièrement avec un risque là
encore d'une nécessité d'augmenter les
provisions avec le même mécanisme et que
plus on retarde cette réévaluation plus
l'impact sur le prix du kilowattheure
sera significatif pour la partie des
bons tellement je souligne que la cour
des comptes parle d'un impact très
faible
je crois que c'est de l'ordre de 2,5 à 5
% sur le prix du kilowattheure en
supposant que les prix du démantèlement
que le montant des provisions pourraient
doubler
là où
en tant qu'organisation de nous
inscrivons un peu en faux par rapport à
ce que dit la cour des comptes c'est que
le doublement de ses charges nous paraît
relativement être une estimation
relativement optimiste si on prend le
cas de brennilis qui est l'un des
réacteurs dont le démantèlement est le
plus avancé en france c'est un réacteur
de toute petite puissance 70 mégawatts
contre des réacteurs aujourd'hui qu'ils
font à peu près 1000 mégawatts en
moyenne sur le parc 70 mégawatts on en
est déjà à plus de 400 millions d'euros
pour le démantèlement
aujourd'hui le chiffre moyen par
réacteur annoncé par edf c'est environ
300 millions d'euros
donc vous voyez que pour une toute
petite puissance on est déjà au delà du
chiffre annoncé par edf donc quand la
cour des comptes dit quand bien même on
doublerait les provisions liées au
démantèlement
ça n'aurait qu'un impact de 2,5 et 4,5
pour cent sur le prix de l'électricité
oui à condition qu'on ne fasse que
doublé on peut imaginer que si elles
sont multipliées par quatre en un pack
de 20% sur le prix de l'électricité donc
c'est pas la même chose pour le volet
assurance du risque nucléaire
c'est un volet qui sera certainement
débat dans les mois qui viennent le
sujet a été relancée notamment par
l'accident nucléaire de fukushima
la france
est soumise à un régime international ou
européen avec une convention
internationale
aujourd'hui le protocole additionnel de
la convention amand a monté les minimum
d'assurance pour les exploitants à 700
millions d'euros
cette convention n'étant pas ratifié
pour l'instant par les autres pays par
l'ensemble des pays elle n'est pas
appliquée en france et donc nous avons
aujourd'hui un montant d'assurance pour
les exploitants à 91 millions d'euros
par réacteur nucléaire le conseil des
ministres a pourtant présenté un projet
de loi il ya quelques semaines je crois
moins de quinze jours qui propose de
relever ce plafond de 91 millions de
plafond de 80 millions à un seuil de 700
millions sera peut-être adopté avec la
nouvelle le nouveau parlement après les
élections présidentielles en tout cas
pour l'instant le montant il est de 91
millions d'euros par réacteur
quand bien même on augmenterait se
chiffre à 700 millions d'euros pour les
exploitants on est quand même dans une
fourchette très basses si on prend le
cas de l'allemagne l'allemagne à un
système de responsabilité illimitée
donc ce que cela signifie c'est qu'en
cas d'accident nucléaire l'exploitant il
est redevable jusqu'au dernier centime
qui aura été déboursés pour gérer la
catastrophe nucléaire en revanche comme
le système d assurance ne peut pas
assumer ce type de système de
responsabilité il y à un montant qui est
fixé à 2,5 milliards pour lequel ils
sont obligés de s'assurer et à côté de
ça si jamais un accident il faudra faire
certainement en vendant ce qu'on appelle
les bijoux de famille n'est donc voilà
donc la france est plutôt sur un niveau
très bas par rapport aux autres pays
européens quand bien même elles
ratifierait le protocole additionnel et
montrer le le seuil à 700 millions
d'euros par acteurs elle reste à un
niveau très bas et lierait scène que
vous avez certainement dû auditionner à
est en train de travailler actuellement
à ce qu'on appelle l'économie de la
sûreté afin d'évaluer combien coûterait
un accident nucléaire en france avec une
fourchette il ya quelques chiffres qui
sont sortis dans la presse et notamment
tués et évoqué par la cour des comptes
ça serait 70 milliards d'euros pour un
petit accident
alors petit ça veut quand même dire avec
des rejets à l'extérieur
jusqu'à éventuellement 600 milliards
d'euros donc vous voyez que les 700
millions que devrais l'exploitant si on
révisait les conventions enfin la loi en
l'occurrence est assez faible par
rapport même un accident mineur qui
serait chiffré à 70 70 milliards d'euros
le reste est pas complètement dues par
l'état puisque ensuite on monte à 1
milliard 5
donc l'état couvrira une partie est bien
évident qu'en cas d'accident nucléaire
on ne se contentera pas de ne pas
indemniser les gens donc il faudra
trouver l'argent quelque part
a priori c'est l'état aujourd'hui qui
aurait la charge d'assumer cette
responsabilité financière alors vous me
direz edf étant à 85% public peut-être
que dans tous les cas ça serait l'état
qui paieraient mais y aurait un système
de responsabilité illimitée avec une
obligation de d'assurance à tour de 2,5
milliards on se rapprocherait plus des
standards européens et internationaux
ça sera aussi beaucoup plus sécurisant
pour la population en tout cas tout ça
ce sont des choses des choses qui vont
être en débat dans les mois qui viennent
et qui pourrait impacter le prix
d'électricité parce que si demain
l'exploitant doit s'assurer à six fois
ce qu'ils assurent aujourd'hui ça aura
un impact sur ses comptes et sur ses
finances donc pour répondre à votre
question numéro un nom le prix actuel
l'électricité pour nous ne reflète pas
la totalité des coûts tout simplement
parce qu'il ya ces externalités qui sont
ou bien pas ou bien peu ou bien mal
prises en compte aujourd'hui et qui
augmenteront certainement dans l'émoi
dans les années à venir selon selon le
la voie que prend le débat
voilà pour la question 1
ce n'est pas pris en compte
mais si greenpeace par exemple le
faisait à ce chiffre
ça se calcule comment faudrait-il pour
le prendre en compte ces coûts externes
que sont le démantèlement les déchets et
l'assurance alors le calcul on peut dire
qu'il est on peut le faire on peut
partir sur une base pour démantèlement
et gestion des déchets ce que edf faire
un calcul
edf dit on pense que ça va nous coûter
temps là où il ya un désaccord et là où
la cour des comptes va plutôt dans nos
temps c'est de dire a priori cette
estimation à les basses donc il faut la
revoir à la hausse après nous en tant qu
elle gère dépendantes on peut fournir
des contrats d un peu friand des
contre-analyses des contre expertises
techniques qui permettraient de dire mon
bas vous dites que ça sera 18 milliards
nous on pense que ça sera 70 et mais in
fine et c'est aussi un peu aux
politiques
je dirais de trancher en utilisant les
éléments techniques
ce qui est important c'est qu'on se
retrouve pas dans 25 ans dans une
situation où on n'a pas provisionné
suffisamment et où il faut augmenter les
provisions est répercuté du coup de
façon brutale sur le prix de
l'électricité
cette hausse des provisions donc voilà
c'est ça qu'on sur lequel on met un
petit warning sur le montant de
l'assurance c'est différent nous c'est
complètement différent salerno on va
défendre un régime de responsabilité
illimitée qui est plus dans l'intérêt du
citoyen évidemment qui est moins dans
l'intérêt de l'industriel parce que ça
peut coûter beaucoup d'argent
après là encore c'est aux politiques de
déterminer qu est ce qui est acceptable
pour la société comme niveau d'assurance
est-ce qu'on accepte qui est une
industrie qui soit très peu pas du tout
assurée ou s&s qu'on sait qu'on ne sait
qu'on ne peux pas l'assurer en totalité
mais en revanche il ya peut-être des
niveaux qui sont plus acceptables que
d'autres donc voila nous entre cohendy
on peut apporter des expertises
indépendantes et extérieur sur des
montants et on peut éventuellement faire
des propositions de modèles de loi mais
pas faire beaucoup plus alors sur la
question de la prolongation de la durée
de vie
et puis les alternatives en fait donc la
situation de la france et une situation
très particulière du fait du là de la
part du nucléaire dans le mix électrique
avec 75 % mais elle est aussi très
particulière parce que ces réacteurs ont
été construits dans un laps de temps
très court
on a entre 77 et 87 80 % du parc
nucléaire qui a été construit ce que ça
signifie c'est que c'est 80 % ils
arriveront à 40 ans en même temps alors
après on peut débattre sur la l'avis
initial prévu pour un réacteur est ce
que ces 30 est-ce que c'est 40 est ce
que ces 50 en l'occurrence les études
techniques montrent qu'on se posait la
question de 30 à 40 ans et que 40 ans
était vue comme une durée de vie
maximale pour des raisons qui sont
techniques qui sont que sur un réacteur
on peut remplacer un certain nombre
d'éléments comme le générateur de vapeur
en revanche il y a deux pièces à ses
maîtresses pour la sûreté que sont la
cuve et l'enceinte de confinement qu'on
ne peut pas remplacer et vous verrez que
ça sera déterminant pour les choix
économiques qu'on fera sur sur le
remplacement du parc nucléaire
donc d'ici 2027 on va être confrontés à
l'obligation de remplacer prolongée ou
substituer 80% de notre parc nucléaire
alors si on prend l'option de le
remplacer ça signifie du 1 pour 0,7 0,6
puisqu'un au père est beaucoup plus gros
les perses beaucoup plus gros que nos
réacteurs actuels cependant le prix du
le coup le coût de production du
mégawatt heure nucléaire qui sort d'un
ep air est aujourd'hui évalué comme
beaucoup plus élevé que le coût de
production actuelle de notre électricité
nucléaire puisque la cour des comptes
parle de 70 à 90 euros le mégawattheure
on est sur un
on peut pas dire un prototype mais en
tout cas on est sur une tête de série à
flamanville et en finlande
donc la cour des comptes ne s'avance pas
sur ce que sera le prix de production
d'électricité nucléaire parent ne perde
en 15 ans en tout cas aujourd'hui a
priori on est sur une fourchette 70 à 90
euros
c'est très élevé c'est par exemple plus
cher que l'éolien onshore donc le lien
terrestre et non pas l'éolien offshore
c'est très élevé et il ya des risques ça
continue de monter pour des raisons qui
sont liées à la sûreté et à la prise en
compte de l'accident de fukushima
donc voilà donc aujourd'hui pour nous
c'est pas crédible de dire qu'on va
remplacer les réacteurs nucléaires
français par des ep air en tout cas
économiquement parlant
ce n'est pas une solution acceptable et
c'est une solution qui entraînera
inévitablement des hausses du prix de
l'électricité au regard du coût actuel
de la technologie
il faut se projeter un tout petit peu
dans le d'historique pour comprendre le
nucléaire est une technologie dont on
dit qu'elle a une courbe d'apprentissage
négative c'est à dire que tout au long
de son histoire les technologies
nucléaires n'ont fait que coûtait plus
cher que ce qu'on pensait et n'ont fait
qu'augmenter pour une raison que tout le
monde comprendra et que certains
estimeront peut-être souhaitable qui est
juste la prise en compte de la sûreté et
le retour d'expérience des différents
accidents donc la génération iii qui
était censé coûter dans les années
soixante dix mille dollars le kilo watt
aujourd'hui la fourchette maximale des
différentes études et notamment des
études de l'agencé pour l'énergie
nucléaire parle de civils dollars le
kilo watt
donc on a vraiment des hausses de coûts
qui sont très importantes et qu'ils
seront encore après fukushima
même si le père prend déjà en compte un
certain nombre de choses puisqu'il prend
en compte le retour d'expérience de
tchernobyl fukushima a mis la lumière
sur un nouveau type de risque et
notamment ce cumul d'accidents qui se
produit au même moment
et le père n'avait pas du tout été conçu
en prenant ce type de situation en
compte donc pour nous le remplacement
d'un réacteur nucléaire par des experts
n'est pas quelque chose d'
économiquement crédible ni souhaitable
il reste deux options qui est la
substitution de la substitution ou
l'extension de la durée de
fonctionnement
je pense que vous l'aurez compris
l'extension de la durée de
fonctionnement et le choix privilégié
des industriels et notamment d'edf mais
pas seulement 1 des industriels
nucléaires dans le monde entier pour une
raison simple c'est qu'une centrale
nucléaire est amorti au bout de vingt à
trente ans de durée de fonctionnement et
que tout ce qui va au-delà permet de
gagner de l'argent ce qui est tout à
fait honorable pour une entreprise
privée comme objectif nous nous avons
plusieurs doute évidemment sur 7 sur
cette option le premier doute bien sûr
vous l'imaginez il a en termes de sûreté
sécurité les phénomènes de
vieillissement se font connaître à
partir de 20 ans
vous pourrez peu près au bout de vingt
ans de durée de fonctionnement pour une
exploitation et il augmente
significativement le risque que se
produise un jour un accident nucléaire
majeur
ça c'est un premier élément pour nous
qui est important et qu'il suffit à
justifier le fait que nous sommes
opposés à l'extension de la durée de
fonctionnement
en revanche il ya un second élément qui
n'est pas notre coeur de métier qui est
là léa économique qui pèse sur cette
option
tout simplement parce qu'aujourd'hui
nous n'avons absolument aucune idée de
ce que seront les coûts de maintenance
du parc nucléaire dans les années à
venir
edf annonce aujourd'hui un plan de 50
milliards auxquels il faudrait ajouter 5
milliards pour le post fukushima
mais ce plan de 50 milliards n'est pas
le premier chiffres que donne au df la
cour des comptes l'ex flic très vraiment
son rapport en 2008 edf parlait de 400
millions d'euros par réacteur pour une
extension de la durée de fonctionnement
au delà de 40 ans ce chiffre est passé à
600 millions d'euros en 2010 et puis il
est passé à 900 millions d'euros début
2011 avant l'accident de fukushima donc
quand edf déclare post fukushima un plan
de 50 milliards d'euros
d'investissements pour faire face
notamment aux obligations de sûreté
après l'accident
ce n'est pas le cas c'est à dire que
c'est 50 milliards existé avait été
annoncé en amont de la catastrophe de
fukushima
en parallèle de sa edf annonce 10
milliards d'euros pour la sûreté post
fukushima dont 5 serait déjà prévu dans
ce plan 50 milliards aujourd'hui les
prescriptions de l'asn ne sont pas
encore adoptées elles n'ont pas été
publiées elles ne sont même pas défini
donc il est impossible de chiffrer
combien coûteront les aménagements de
sûreté postérieure à la catastrophe de
fukushima
donc c'est un peu ce que je veux vous
dire c'est qu'il ya un aléa économique
très fort sur le coût de la maintenance
d'un parc nucléaire dans l'optique
d'obtenir un prolongement de la durée de
fonctionnement au delà de 40 ans c'est
aléas économiques
il va être aggravée par la lea sur la
durée de fonctionnement elle même c'est
à dire que c'est pas parce que vous
investissez 55 milliards d'euros que
l'asm va dire vous pouvez aller jusqu'à
60 ans en france ça marche pas comme ça
la loi dit je sais vous allez pouvoir de
la changer mais aujourd'hui la loi dit
qu'il faut une visite décennale et que
tous les dix ans au maximum
il y à un réexamen du niveau de sûreté
des réacteurs qui permettra de décider
si le réacteur est en état de continuer
à fonctionner un an deux ans trois ans
quatre ans ou plus c'est comme ça que ça
marche et l'asn est très clair sur ce
sujet ils n'ont pas l'intention de
changer ce système ils ne donneront pas
un blanc-seing pour 20 ans avec des f et
aujourd'hui ils sont incapable de vous
dire est ce que les cuves seront dans un
état qui permette la poursuite du
fonctionnement d'une installation passé
40 ans on ne sait pas vous ne savez pas
ils ne savent pas et si ils
s'aperçoivent que les culs que certaines
des cuves des réacteurs ne permettent
pas la poursuite de fonctionnement ils
n'hésiteront pas à demander l'arrêt d'un
réacteur
voilà ça signifie qu'on investit donc ça
signifie qu'on a investi 55 milliards
d'euros minimum mais peut-être plus pour
une durée de fonctionnement qu'on est
incapable de prévoir et je voudrais
attirer votre attention sur un phénomène
qui est assez étrange qui est que edf
parce que c'est une entreprise publique
pourrait parfois avoir tendance à faire
des investisse
financièrement plus risqué que ce que
ferait des entreprises privées je vais
vous donner un exemple très concret
c'est le cas des projets nucléaires au
royaume uni
aujourd'hui et c'est connu de tout le
monde
il ya un rapport de citigroup sur le
sujet en matière d'énergie le nucléaire
est l'énergie la plus capitalistiques
qui demande le plus d'investissement
capital à lorie en capital à l'origine
le capital investissement c'est très
cher à la construction c'est moins cher
au fonctionnement c'est comme ça que ils
s'y retrouvent avec l'augmentation des
coûts des dernières générations
il faut trouver des incitations fortes
réglementaires notamment pour permettre
de rendre les deals financièrement
intéressant le fait d'investir dans la
construction d'une centrale nucléaire
citigroup a sorti un rapport très
intéressant qui s'appelle new nuclear no
5 ce qui montre que s'il n'y a pas ou
bien une sécurisation des tarifs d'achat
ou bien des incitations via des
mécanismes de co2 d'achat de la tonne
carbone etc
c'est trop dangereux financièrement pour
un établissement privé d'investir dans
un projet de construction d'une nouvelle
centrale nucléaire
donc c'est un fait ça veut dire qu'il
faut des soutien très fort des états
aujourd'hui il ya une semaine
art w et on se retire des projets
nucléaires au royaume uni
évidemment ne soyons pas simpliste il
n'y a pas une raison à ça j'imagine bien
que la réorientation stratégique de
l'allemagne les incite à le faire mais
quand les pdg déclare qu aujourd'hui les
plus intéressants financièrement en
termes de retour sur investissement
d'investir dans des renouvelables tôt
d'investir dans du nucléaire c'est aussi
un signal relativement négatif envoyé
aux marchés sur la construction de
nouvelles centrales nucléaires
donc on peut se poser la question de
comment edf se retrouve à être la seule
entreprise privée publique pardon à
investir sur un marché dont les
entreprises privées se retire et c'est
là que je dis que
pour nous c'est une vraie interrogation
quel est le rôle d'edf est ce qu edf est
toujours une entreprise de service
public qui se doit d'investir ses angles
de faire des investissements pour la
sécurisation du système électrique
français dans les 20 30 40 ans qui
viennent ou est ce qu'elle fait des
investissements risqués sur des marchés
à l'étranger et pour l'instant quand
même l'impression qu'elle fait des
investissements risqués sur des marchés
à l'étranger ça se pose aussi pour
l'extension de la durée de
fonctionnement
c'est un investissement risqué investir
55 milliards d'euros dans une
technologie dont on ne sait pas
finalement si elle coûtera plus il ne
coûtera pas plus mais en plus dont on ne
sait pas combien de temps elle pourra
fonctionner c'est un investissement qui
est très risqué et s'il n'y a pas eu d f
avec le logo de l'état derrière edf
entreprises publiques posé la question à
des banquiers je ne crois pas que vous
avez auditionné beaucoup de banquiers
demandez leur s'ils sont prêts à
financer sur leurs fonds personnels
une telle un tel investissement je ne
suis pas sûr qu ils vous répondront
favorablement
donc vous l'aurez compris ma réponse à
votre question numéro deux c'est que
nous sommes pour une sortie progressive
du nucléaire avec des investissements
massifs dans des énergies de
substitution que sont les énergies
renouvelables je vous conseille le
fabuleux outil sortie par bloomberg qui
montre à quelle date le l'énergie
solaire à atteindre à ce qu'on appelle
le grid parity selon les pays et selon
le niveau de taux de retour sur
investissement qu'on attend c'est très
intéressant on voit que la france en
france le solaire attendre à ce fameux
grid parity entre 2014 et 2016
donc plus le temps passera plus les
années renouvelables seront compétitives
- le nucléaire sera compétitif et donc
le maintien de ce choix là n'est que
politique
alors il y avait une question aussi dans
la question de sur la quatrième
génération si j'ai bien compris
alors c'est pas ma spécialité cependant
la quatrième génération n'est pas une en
tout cas telle qu'elle existe en france
à savoir des réacteurs au sodium
donc aujourd'hui c'est le projet
principalement astrid qui a reçu un
milliard d'euros dans le cadre du grand
emprunt il y a un an et demi et qui est
menée par le cea sur le site de marcoule
ce n'est pas la première expérimentation
ou projets de recherche de réacteurs au
sodium puisque super phénix était déjà
un réacteur au sodium et je crois qu'il
y a de très bons rapports du sénat sur
l'arête superphénix et sur son
fonctionnement
il existe toute une polémique qui
voudrait dire que superphénix a été
arrêté pour des raisons politiques par
un gouvernement de gauche je crois
sous la pression des écologistes mais si
l'on regarde la fonctionnement de
superphénix pendant le temps où il a été
en activité
on voit qu'en réalité techniquement
c'était très compliqué de le faire
marcher et de le rendre rentable donc la
raison les raisons pour lesquelles il a
été arrêté sont beaucoup plus diverses
et variées que le seul la seule
opposition des écologistes
c'est une filière dans laquelle le ceva
a souhaité continuer d'investir en
proposant ce réacteur astrid aujourd'hui
rien ne nous permet de dire que astrid
fonctionnerait mieux que superphénix est
pas sans savoir qui est le podium
présente notamment de gros inconvénients
techniques et économiques puisqu'il a
besoin d'être maintenues dans un état
liquide en permanence ce qui fait par
exemple qu'aujourd'hui alors que nous
sommes plus de 15 ans 12 15 ans après
l'arrêt de superphénix nous devons
toujours refroidir en permanence les
cuves de sodium pour éviter un accident
industriel
donc c'est une technologie qui est
particulièrement risquée qui n'a pas
fait ses preuves pour l'instant qu'ils
marchent pas bien et dans laquelle on
investit encore un milliard d'euros au
minimum
ça demandera certainement plus donc
voila vous l'aurez compris pour nous
c'est pas quelque chose de souhaitable
c'est un horizon de temps ce qui est
très lointain n'avons aucune certitude
que ce projet sera développé en 2030 ou
or d'ici là on sera déjà dans cette
problématique de goulets d'étranglement
les que le 4 les 80 % du parc nucléaire
ont atteint 40 ans de fonctionnement
donc on a besoin de faire des
investissements avant bien avant cette
date est pour nous investir de l'argent
dans astrid est une perte de temps sans
parler des problématiques liées et
d'argent sans parler des problématiques
liées à la prolifération puisque
j'imagine que edf et areva vous ont
expliqué que l'objectif de ce réacteur
était qu'il pouvait notamment fonctionné
à la fois avec de l'uranium appauvri
mais aussi avec du plutonium
ce qui signifie transport à nouveau des
transport de plutonium et puis
l'utilisation du plutonium dans un
réacteur
s'ils augmentent le niveau de risque
donc pour nous c'est clairement pas un
choix souhaitable ni en termes
économiques ni en termes de sûreté
voilà donc pour les questions iii et iv
je renvoie à auclair la question 5 sur
l'intermittence
à vouliez l'intermittence à la pointe
donc je prendrai peut-être quelques
exemples étrangers et notamment
l'exemple allemand où au final les
énergies renouvelables fournissent plus
d'électricité que le nucléaire puisque
elles fournissent un peu plus de 20% et
le nucléaire un peu moins de 20%
donc je ne suis pas sûr que quand on en
est à 20 % du mix électrique on puisse
parler d'appoint cependant il y a un
problème d'intermittence il est tout à
fait réelle greenpeace sort tous les
deux ans depuis 2006
un scénario de transition énergétique
qui s'appelle révolution énergétique qui
aujourd'hui n'existe pas à l'échelle
française qui existe à l'échelle
européenne et à l'échelle mondiale dans
lequel on réduit en fait
significativement ce qu'on appelle la
base aujourd'hui la base du mix
électrique française est entièrement
nucléaire et elle est très importante
dont l'essai est dans des scénarios
futurs ont réduit significativement
cette base et on développe massivement
les réseaux ce qu'on appelle les smart
grid et donc c'est comme ça que nous
résolvons de problèmes d'intermittence
notamment en utilisant les réseaux
je pense que si vous avez auditionné des
gens du scénario négawatt
ils vous expliqueront que eux
développent le stockage par exemple de
l'électricité à travers la méthane la
technologie de la méta nation il ya
plusieurs façons de le faire hein
l'espagne et la suisse font déjà du
stockage d'électricité à travers ce
système combiné éolienne hydraulique où
ils utilisent donc l'électricité
produite par les éoliennes pour remonter
l'eau des barrages qui permettent ce qui
est une forme de stockage électricité il
ya deux d'autres formes de stockage et
christer ce qui est sûr c'est que il ya
encore besoin d' avancées technologiques
sur ces sujets là que sont les réseaux
et que son stockage de l'électricité et
qu'on n'y arrivera certainement pas tant
que la r&d public en matière d'énergie
sera allouée à 60% à la recherche
nucléaire puisque aujourd'hui seulement
20% attirer des publics en matière
d'énergie va aux énergies renouvelables
donc qu'il y ait encore des défis à
relever je pense que nous ne le nions
pas en revanche il faut
mettre les investissements nécessaires
derrière les défis enfin de permettre
ces fameuses rupture technologique mais
on a un peu de marche quand même
puisqu'on n'est qu'à 12 % de production
électrique en provenance de
renouvelables dont la très grosse
majorité vient de l'hydroélectricité
donc on a quand même le temps de
développer les énergies renouvelables
tout en cherchant ses solutions de
stockage et de et de transport à travers
les splendides la consommation dans
votre dernière question en effet c'est
un point qui est fondamental pour nous
tout simplement parce que c'est un
argument qu'on entend beaucoup le prix
d'électricité en france en comparaison
d'autres pays donc je crois que avant
tout il serait intéressant de faire une
comparaison avec l'allemagne où d'après
les informations que j'ai ce qui fait la
différence de prix du kilowattheure
entre l'allemagne et la france ne serait
non pas le coût de production mais les
taxes et les coûts liés au transport de
l'électricité l'état que ce sont trois
fois plus élevées en allemagne sur
l'électricité qu'elles ne le sont en
france puisqu'elle représente 12 % du
coût du prix final de l'électricité
contre 4% en france donc il faut faire
attention c'est pas forcément le choix
de la production qui entraîne les
différences de coûts c'est plutôt le
choix politique qui lie à derrière
notamment les taxes
ça c'est un premier élément le deuxième
élément c'est que le fait que le
kilowattheure en france soit peu élevés
ne signifient pas que le consommateur
paie une facture d'électricité qui elle
même serait peu élevé tout simplement
parce que nous consommons beaucoup plus
d'électricité que nos voisins je pense
pas que ce soit moi qui vais vous
apprendre que nous avons développé un
parc électronucléaire très dimensionné
rendre compte que certains disent
surdimensionné et qu'il a fallu inciter
à la consommation d'électricité pour
rentabiliser cet investissement s'est
passé par le développement du chauffage
électrique qui est présent aujourd'hui
dans 30% des logements français et qui
est présent dans 60 % des logements
neufs mis sur le marché
donc c'est
c'est pour nous une catastrophe dans la
mesure où le chauffage électrique va
parfois représenter jusqu'à 30% de la
consommation en période de pointe
c'est énorme 30% de la consommation en
période de pointe donc vous posez la
question déjà de quel type d'action pour
faire baisser la consommation
le bâtiment l'habitat représentant une
très grosse partie de la consommation
d'électricité
la première action c'est d'agir sur sur
cela évidemment ça passe par l'isolation
mais ça passe aussi par le remplacement
ou le bannissement du chauffage
électrique
alors évidemment dans les logements
neufs il est aberrant d'avoir du louvre
du chauffage électrique dans des
logements neufs
ça sera beaucoup plus difficile de
bannir le chauffage électrique dans les
logements anciens
et il ya peut-être quelque chose qu'il
est intéressant d'étudier qui est
l'incitation tarifaire
aujourd'hui les usagers payent tous le
même prix lors kilowattheure y compris
en période de pointe
alors que la pointe et pour 30% liées au
chauffage électrique en période
hivernale il ne serait pas
inenvisageable de faire payer
peut-être plus cher les consommateurs
qui ont du chauffage électrique ce qui
permettrait non seulement d'inciter le
remplacement des convecteurs électriques
par d'autres convecteurs électriques
plus performants
s'il n'y a pas d'autres solutions et
puis peut-être aussi le développement de
solutions de chauffage collectif ou
alternatifs à l'électricité donc
clairement pour nous
le focus il est à mettre sur l'habitat
voilà
solution politique radicale mais
l'énergie est un choix politique
l'électricité vous avons donné toute une
tradition sur la péréquation
d'électricité c'est vrai mais c'est un
vrai oui et c'est un vrai sujet dans la
mesure où je n'ai pas une connaissance
approfondie du sujet mais je pense que
le logement social en france doit être
massivement équipés en chauffage
électrique puisque ses skis à l'achat
coûte le moins cher donc malheureusement
le chauffage électrique sanctionne les
plus pauvres qui ont des factures
d'électricité forcément très importante
puisque le chauffage électrique si vous
en avez un chez vous vous le saurez
coûte très cher faut que ce soit très
bien isolé merci beaucoup
les positions de greenpeace sont très
clairs sur toute une série de sujets
monsieur le rapporteur
avez vous besoin d'un complément de
précisions sur l'une ou l'autre des
questions et des réponses qui vous ont
été apportées bien que l'ensemble des
réponses étaient précise claire
argumenté j'ai eu malgré tout quelques
questions complémentaires
première question vous avez parlé de la
durée de vie des centrales actuelles et
certains pères certaines personnes
auditionnées nous en nous ont dit qu'il
y avait certaines centrales américaines
qui ont fonctionné 60 ans dont cloud est
votre avis sur ce point la deuxième
question
sur le développement du photovoltaïque
donc vous avez insisté sur les
investissements nécessaires dans
l'éolien onshore 1 c'est à dire celui
qui était à des prix aujourd'hui de 60 à
80 euros le mégawattheure donc était en
compétition avec nucléaire il ya quand
même les prix du off shore qui sont à la
fois plus cher et est-ce que quelle est
la position de greenpeace par rapport à
l'offshore parce que c'est aussi des
grandes installations et puis par
rapport au photovoltaïque on nous a
parlé quand même 2 2 de panneaux
fabriqués qui n'était plus fabriqués en
europe et qui étaient fabriqués avec
beaucoup de co2 est bas et qui aussi
porté atteinte à des filières
industrielles est ce que vous avez une
réflexion sur ce point là par exemple
par rapport à d'autres systèmes de
chauffage parce qu'au bon l'argument de
personnes auditionnées qui nous ont dit
mais le chauffage et rick ça peut être
très bien à condition de bien isoler un
et à condition qu'on est politique
d'isolation thermique intéressante donc
quelle est votre position par rapport à
une résolution isolation des bâtiments
qui serait réussi à ce moment là qui
permettrait que ce type de chauffage et
dernière question monsieur le président
dans quel organisme
greenpeace est elle associée à fléchir
par rapport à la politique d'énergie
c'est à dire si on considère que vous
êtes une association de défense de
l'environnement au sens large 1 et est
ce que il ya des comités de réflexion
sur l'énergie avec eux les producteurs
d'électricité end
est ce que vous êtes associé à plusieurs
organismes nationaux de réflexion sur le
développement de la stratégie
énergétique
américaine à mon avis que ce qu'ont
voulu dire voilà je pense que ce dont tu
parlais vos interlocuteurs c'est
l'obtention d'une extension de la
licence pour les centrales américaines
aujourd'hui aucun réacteur dans le monde
n'a jamais fonctionné au delà de 47 ans
jamais d'aucun modèle il ya environ 133
réacteurs qui sont aujourd'hui fermées
un peu partout autour du globe
leur moyenne d'âge est de 22 ans donc
donc pour l'instant non les réacteurs
d'américains n'ont jamais fonctionné 60
ans en revanche ce qui est vrai c'est
que l'autorité de sûreté américaine
fonctionne différemment de la nôtre et
qu'elle a d'ores et déjà donné de
nouvelles licences
voilà donc elle a donné de nouvelles
licences les américains ont une licence
pour 40 ans de fonctionnement et ensuite
ils ont demandé des licences pour 20
nouvelle année supplémentaire et une
grosse partie du parc a obtenu cette
autorisation d'exploitation pour 20 ans
à la différence de la france il n'y a
pas d'examen de sûreté décennale aux
états unis c'est une mesure qu'on peut
juger contestable dans la mesure où ça
signifie qu' on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer pendant 20 ans et aux etats unis
c'est à la gendarme à l'autorité de
sûreté d'apporter la preuve d'une
défaillance de sûreté et non inverse
alors que chez nous c'est l'inversé
c'est surprenant matière de sûreté
voilà pour l'éolien alors greenpeace est
plutôt en faveur de l'éolien offshore
nous estimons que nous aurons besoin des
différentes sources de production
renouvelable en revanche là où je pense
nous sommes peut-être un peu en
désaccord avec la politique énergétique
telle qu'elle est faite actuellement
c'est que nous prenons un système plus
décentralisé
là on remplace beaucoup on remplace on
ajoute en fait de grosses unités de
production centralisé
ça signifie parfois de nouvelles tht des
investissements dans le réseau et ça
maintient un système qui aujourd'hui
n'est clairement pas celui que nous
défendons nous sommes plutôt pour un
système très décentralisé où le
consommateur devient producteur d'une
partie de sa consommation
après évidemment nous aurons besoin
d'unité d'appoint centralisée qui
peuvent être de l'éolien offshore qui
peuvent être d unité biomasse qui elles
ne sont pas intermittente
voilà donc tout ça ce sont des questions
qu'on va beaucoup élucidés dans le
scénario qu'on est en train de
travailler et qu'on sortira en septembre
qui sera le scénario énergétique pour la
france de greenpeace et qui donnera nos
préférences en fonction des différentes
sources d'énergie renouvelables
clairement nous ne sommes pas opposés à
l'éolien offshore mais c'est dommage que
nous réfléchissions en permanence à
ajouter des moyens de production
centralisé ça répond pas tout à fait à
ce qui pour nous est la nécessité d'un
changement de paradigme énergétique
exactement les panneaux solaires alors
il faut voir que quand bien même les
panneaux solaires sont fabriqués en
chine ils ont un bilan co2 qui de toute
façon restera toujours inférieur aux
combustibles fossiles
je vous rappelle que l'uranium est
extrait un peu partout sur le globe mais
certainement pas en france
donc quand on parle de bilan co2
généralement on fait ce qu'on appelle
une analyse de cycle de vie et on prend
les émissions sur la totalité du cycle
de vie neil nucléaire ni
énergies renouvelables ont un bilan nul
tout simplement parce qu'il faut bien
extraire des matières premières et que
cette extraction
aujourd'hui elle nécessite de l'énergie
ainsi que leur transport maintenant si
on prend par exemple quelques chiffres
en termes d'emploi les énergies
renouvelables ont un facteur
d'employabilité ou en tout cas
produisent plus d'emplois que le
nucléaire
si on prend juste le cas de l'allemagne
il y à 390 mille emplois directs qui
sont associées aux énergies
renouvelables
je dis bien direct alors sur le
nucléaire en france j'ai l'impression
que les chiffres ces derniers mois ne
sont plus très clair mais si vous
regardez l'étude de price il ya 125
mille emplois directs et puis ensuite
des emplois indirects puis des emplois
induits
donc on est quand même sur des facteurs
qui sont bien inférieurs ça signifie
qu'en fait que on emploie huit fois
moins de personnes dans le nucléaire en
france qu'il d'un emploi en allemagne
dans les renouvelables
donc quand bien même la totalité du
panneau solaire ne seraient pas
fabriqués sur le sol français
ce sur quoi je vous avoue que je n'ai
peu d'informations évidemment la chine
est un gros producteur au lobby panneaux
solaires je sais qu'il reste quelques
producteurs français je suis pas capable
de vous dire si on a perdu entièrement
la filière industrielle du panneau
solaire
mais quand bien même le besoin en
installation c'est celui là qui demande
le plus de main-d'oeuvre et celui là il
n'est pas délocalisable
voilà donc de toutes façons les énergies
renouvelables sont un secteur je sais
pas si on peut tout les regrouper en un
seul secteur et l'efficacité énergétique
qui à mon avis est l'un des secteurs qui
doit te fais le plus d'emplois qui
aujourd'hui créer plus d'emplois que le
nucléaire
pour un kilowatt heure produit si vous
voulez voilà le chauffage électrique
dans tous les cas le chauffage
électrique
il fait augmenter la pointe donc je
dirai évidemment la priorité c'est une
isolation correct de l'habitat parce que
c'est la façon la plus efficace de
lutter contre le gaspillage
d'électricité
cependant l'ajout de chauffage
électrique et notamment les 60% dans le
les bâtiments neufs de toute façon sont
une catastrophe parce que ils font
augmenter la pointe le parc nucléaire
français il est dimensionné sur la
pointe maximale sur dix ans donc
qu'est-ce que ça signifie ça signifie
que toute l'année on produit trop sauf
peut-être un jour le 10 février où on
produit pas assez
donc c'est vraiment un système qui
s'autodétruit quoi veut dire que le
reste du temps on va exporter alors que
l'europe en a peu besoin
et quand on en a besoin il va falloir
qu'on importe parce que de toute façon
comme on ajoute du chauffage électrique
on continue d'augmenter la pointe donc
je dirais que tout ce qui fait grossir
cette pointe n'est pas pertinent et
dommageable et pour les prix de
l'électricité et pour la sûreté ou
est-ce que nous sommes associés
aujourd'hui la seule structure
institutionnelle à laquelle nous
participons sur l'énergie je ne veux pas
dire d'erreur parce que nous sommes
nombreux mais je crois que c'est le haut
comité pour l'information et la
transparence en matière de sécurité
nucléaire
donc c'est beaucoup plus sur la sûreté
que sur l'énergie en soi où nous sommes
membres en revanche dans le cas de ce
haut comité nos travaillons sur un
rapport sur la participation du public
au processus de décision en matière
nucléaire et un de nos constats et qu'il
y à un manque de participation du public
à l'échelle
comment dire sectorielle à savoir au
dessus du projet au niveau du projet il
ya plutôt une bonne participation
mais au niveau de la mise en place de la
réglementation il ya une très faible
participation et on prenait l'exemple
paraît pas par exemple du comité sur la
paix pays qui est ce comité composé
d'industriels de quelques associations
qui réfléchit à la programmation
pluriannuelle des investissements
nous ne sommes pas membres de ce comité
aujourd'hui est en effet une des
demandes du rapport et d'ouvrir ce type
de comités non seulement à des
associations
plus largement mais aussi à des experts
d'autres secteurs et pas uniquement à
des experts technologiques à savoir à
des sociologues et des politologues à
des économies
puisque l'enjeu n'est pas que technique
en matière de nucléaire ce qui est
important c'est quand même l'acceptation
du risque donc c'est important de parler
avec des sociologues par exemple donc
voilà donc nous nous sommes assez peu
présent assez peu associée à ce type de
réflexion mais aussi j'ai dansé celi
locales dans certaines centrales
oui nous sommes dans plusieurs clients
tout parce qu'on est que deux voilà donc
on peut pas être dans toutes les quilles
non parce que les clients d'abord il
faut avoir un ancrage local pour rentrer
dans une crise donc ça c'est une
discussion qu'on a eue avec plusieurs
clips parce que on estime que quand bien
même on n'est pas toujours ancrés
localement on peut quand même avoir
quelque chose à apporter au débat donc
j'avais la discussion notamment avec
tricastin avec la cli de tricastin où on
n'avait pas pu rentrer donc on est
présent dans les clés de la manche
puisque mon collègue est situé vie dans
la manche donc il a un intérêt direct
celle de la hague celle de flamanville
et celle du centre de stockage de la
manche
nous sommes au comité et par ailleurs
nous sommes en train d'essayer de
rentrer dans les clips du blayais est
une et une autre clé je crois que c'est
celle de budget donc par l'intermédiaire
de nos groupes locaux sur le terrain
mais nos groupes locaux ne sont pas des
salariés
ce sont des bénévoles donc ils n'ont pas
forcément le temps d'aller dans les
commissions locales d'information ils
n'ont pas forcément les connaissances
que nous avons été plus difficile pour
eux c'est pour ça que nous ne sommes pas
dans toute l'équipe donc aujourd'hui les
structures dans lesquelles on essaie des
structures qui parle sûreté sécurité
mais pas vraiment énergie jean pierre
vial oui une observation une question
une observation j'ai été un peu étonné
quand on pourrait parler du nucléaire
comme énergie de pointe c'est plutôt
quand même une énergie de base
oui j'ai 10.2 c'était une erreur mais
par contre le chauffage électrique
augmente la pointe voilà d'accord par
contre que vous avez évoqué les smart
green que vous avez évoqué les
productions que vous auriez à moyen ou
long terme sur un certain nombre de
dorian tensions politiques
je vous pose une question je pense est
moins mal compris que tout à l'heure
lorsque je les pose et en parlant
d'autoconsommation puisqu'on mon
interlocuteur a pris ça comme le loto
commencé nations industrielles alors que
je parlais plus tôt consommation des
particuliers en faisant référence au
modèle allemand qui a abandonné la
rémunération de la rémunération
électrique notamment dans le
photovoltaïque à la mise sur réseau un
consommation sur place or là on est au
coeur effectivement d'un nouveau modèle
et delà de la consommation par le
producteur l'usagé avec je dirais toutes
les nouvelles visions des smart grids
quelle est votre position là dessus oui
alors très clairement c'est vraiment pas
un sujet dans lequel j'ai une expertise
pointue
en revanche je sais que les personnes
avec lesquelles nous travaillons évoque
souvent cette problématique qui est
qu'en france on est obligé de revendre
l'électricité pour la racheter
alors que en allemagne ils peuvent
consommer directement l'électricité
qu'ils produisent et a priori les gens
avec lesquels nous travaillons comme
leclerc soutiennent plutôt un système à
l'allemande
moi j'ai pas de panneaux solaires sur
mon toit donc ça dépend j'imagine de la
fluctuation des prix
si vous achetez si vous achetez très bas
ou très cher aujourd'hui est de racheter
sur le jeu directement parce qu'on a les
tarifs régulés des tarifs d'achat mais
je vous dis c'est vraiment pas un sujet
sur lequel je suis expert donc je vous
conseille de demander à raphaël claustré
sans point de vue précis j'ai un satan
de bris de démantèlement de sur la
gestion et mais je sais pas si vous
donnant beaucoup plus d'informations que
ce qu'ils ont donné à accorder compte un
champion je veux juste te rassurer
madame magnoni d'un signal aux a bien
dit au départ qu'elle ne répondrait pas
aux questions 3 et 4 que c'était pas de
son domaine de compétences ce qui est
tout à fait son droit donc vas-y à toi
j'ai évoqué un scénario qu'il allait
sortir la prochaine main sur un peu
l'avenir et à dicter la france alors que
les chiffres aient tout ça elle est ce
que les chiffres et les hypothèses
comprennent très alors chiffré mais
c'est difficile de ce fait car quand
vous parlez de vous parler que vous
dites et que les lakers ou qu'edf au le
céleri mêlée taurasi n'y aurait pas que
les chemins de fer donc
l'état a soutenu qu'on les russes voilà
donc et puis également une chondrite que
les airs il râle cléroux la recrue
beaucoup d'emplois bon c'est vrai mais
moi qui s'y consignes générales les
sociales à la crise en plein département
pour le marché qui les paie quoi c'est
pas que je revienne sur le côté alors
d'abord qu'on s'entende bien l'état
soutient edf l'état est actionnaire à 80
5% d'edf et nous ne remettons pas en
cause le modèle public d'edf au
contraire nous nous posons la question
de est ce que ce qu'edf est toujours une
entreprise de service publique française
sur le chiffrage je sais que les gens
qui travaillent sur le scénario négawatt
travaille actuellement sur un chiffrage
c'est quelque chose qui se fait par
étapes donc nous c'est la première fois
que greenpeace va sortir un scénario
énergétique pour la france donc on va
déjà commencer par sortir le scénario en
tant que tel avec les choix
technologiques et les options il y aura
quelques ordres de grandeur sur des
investissements mais exactement comme
c'est difficile pour edf de chiffrer ses
coûts de maintenance dans les 20
prochaines années
c'est aussi difficile de déterminer le
montant des investissements surtout pour
des énergies dont les coûts diminuent en
permanence et très rapidement mais oui
il y aura un certain nombre de chiffres
je sais pas si ça répondra à vos
attentes mais où il y aura déchire de
toute façon le besoins en
investissements il est là il existe
partout qu'on choisisse de maintenir
l'option nucléaire en prolongeant
l'extension de vie qu'on choisisse de
remplacer par du nucléaire ou qu'on
choisisse de substituer par d'autres
sources d'énergie il y aura besoin
d'investissements après en effet tout
dépend du niveau d'investissement
vous avez raison
je rapporte en demanderait bien eu un
mot de conclusion aussi une précision à
nos un mot de conclusion à madame
magnoni par rapport à notre mission d'
enquête
c'est par rapport au thème nous avons
abordé ce que vous auriez une réflexion
de conclusion mais tu n'as pas ta vanité
auditions pour faire part conclusion
monsieur le rapporteur
bon il vous tend une perche non il ya un
sujet qu'on n'a pas du tout abordé c'est
le fait que d'après ce que dit la creux
le prix de l'électricité augmentera de
30% d'ici 2016 et que ça c'est une
réalité il ya beaucoup d'interlocuteurs
qui estime qu' aujourd'hui le prix de
l'électricité ne reflète pas la réalité
de son couple de son coût réel donc a
priori le prix d'électricité risque de
continuer d'augmenter
voilà donc ça on en a pas on n'en a pas
beaucoup parlé ensuite très clairement
la position de greenpeace c'est que dans
les dix ans qui viennent on a ce que
tout le monde perçoit comme une chape de
plomb et un terrible une terrible
décision mais en fait on a une vraie
opportunité économique de développer des
secteurs et des filières industrielles
qui soit performante et qui soit aussi
des secteurs de pointe exactement comme
le nucléaire a été un secteur de pointe
pendant plus de 30 ans et on a une vraie
opportunité de créer de l'emploi de
créer de la richesse en amorçant cette
transition énergétique je ne vois pas
nous ne voyons pas forcément ça comme
comme quelque chose d'horrible qui va
multiplier les prix de l'électricité par
12 et qui va nous faire semblait sombrer
dans une terrible crise je crois qu'il
ya beaucoup d'hypocrisie sur le sujet et
je prendrai un seul exemple c'est le cas
japonais nous ne prenons pas une sortie
rapide du nucléaire en
un an avec une substitution par du
pétrole et du gaz le japon a pas eu le
choix
en un an ils ont dû sortir du nucléaire
tout simplement parce qu'ils n'ont plus
qu'un réacteur aujourd'hui qui
fonctionne pendant pendant un an tous
les industriels ont crié à deux
réacteurs
il me semblait que c'était plus qu'un
même si vous dites 2 je vous crois en
tout cas il reste plus grand chose
tous les industriels ont crié au loup en
avant l'hiver en annonçant des coupures
d'électricité inévitable des black out
etc
ça ne s'est pas produit donc je pense
que la réalité parfois un peu loin de
l'image qu'on s'en fait et au lieu de
voir la transition énergétique comme un
poids peut-être qu'il serait temps qu'on
essaye d'en faire vraiment une
opportunité économique
ce sera le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
je vois sur le rapporteur pose
régulièrement la question de la
prévision de la creux sur l'augmentation
des tarifs de 30 % jusqu'en 2016 mais il
évite de poser la question à qui il veut
il pensait que la question j'ai parlé d'
apparu en vue de vous la poser à vous
mes parcours c'était tout à fait votre
droit de nous donner votre avis sur
cette position a cru merci beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à toutes nos questions
et d'avoir répondu avec conviction mais
bon vous êtes non mais greenpeace est
une association qui est très bonne en
terme de communication et beaucoup de
positions que vous avez rappelé devant
la commission sont des positions que
nous avons eu l'occasion les uns les
autres veut découvrir à l'occasion de
telle ou telle déclaration ou récentes
ou plus anciennes ont tous les cas merci
beaucoup à vous de vous êtes prêter à ce
jeu des questions réponses et d'avoir
répondu avec précision
voilà pour les travaux de la commission
d' enquête sur le coût réel de
l'électricité pour revoir cette audition
elle est disponible en vod sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr bonne
journée à tous